ça commence comme ça
on va chialer avant la fin
le nouveau chapeau de
et ça c'est toi je suis venu te dire que
je m'en vais ah ça fait très plaisir
ça c'est moi voilà
[Musique]
il est vraiment
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter
il est vraiment
je vous demande de vous arrêter
[Musique]
allô allô ouais c'est moi ça va ça va tu
as vu ce qui se passe là tout le monde
en parle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui parle avec
nous ce soir
Jean-Marie Bigard
Charlotte Gainsbourg
Alain Chabat
Jamel Debbouze Michel Bernier
Jean-Louis Aubert
Ellie Semoun Marc Lavoine
Florent Pagny Arthur et Estelle
Yvan Attal
Frédéric
Gérard Darmon
liane folie Laurent Ruquier
Dany Boon j'aime bien te forcer
Bruno Gaccio
Omar et Fred
Christophe
Dominique Segal le blanchetterie
je suis venu te dire que déjà
[Musique]
comme dit il y avait couvrant c'est
triste une dernière alors qu'est-ce que
tu veux c'est un petit cadeau pour toi
pour les vacances pour la plage pour
papier
voilà
pour cet été c'est bien on est là quoi
de mieux
avec ça sur les plages sur les plages
abandonnées coquillages et crustacés
je crois qu'il faut dire à nos amis que
tous les tableaux qui sont exposés sur
ce plateau sont en vente au profit de
l'association leur aide Fugain et voilà
et si vous n'avez pas d'argent donnez
vos plaquettes et voilà
loin loin de la région du cœur n'importe
où la peau change de couleur
Jean-Marie Bigard
[Musique]
merci merci
bonsoir bonsoir
j'explique à nos amis téléspectateurs
donc j'ai demandé à tous les invités ce
soir de me poser une question et de
poser une question alors ma fille
la question je voulais te poser c'est
est-ce que tu as déjà envoyé les stocks
de boissons à Canal parce que il y avait
rien dans ma loge
en plastique ça sent la fin on est
désolé là comment tu as pu te faire
virer comme une merde comme ça il est
vraiment
et pour le lot je suis content qu'il
soit viré avec toi parce que comme ça il
va écrire un sketch ou deux pour mon
prochain spectacle on va en parler
d'abord en rangeant des cassettes pour
réparer cette dernière émission j'ai
trouvé un truc drôle
c'était toi un soir ici ah oui j'ai été
drôle
vas-y fais péter il faut que tout le
monde dise manitocerge 1 2 3
alors est-ce que tu mets des survêts le
week-end je mets un survêt répondais
aussi bête que ta question je m'as
survête quand je fais du sport
j'ai fait du sport tous les jours alors
vous reculer et est-ce que tu te grattes
est-ce que tu est-ce que tu te gratte
les couilles sans voix par jour par
exemple non mais je sais pas moi je te
demande les couilles ça fois par jour je
vais saigner au bout d'un moment
est-ce que hey j'arrive je me gratte les
couilles tous les matins ce que ne peut
pas faire Nadine parce qu'elle n'a pas
de gouilles qu'est-ce qu'il tient bien
le terrain
non mais Nadine en même temps c'est mon
interview
toute la France rougit de ta conduite
est-ce que tu est-ce que tu justement on
y arrive à la conduite est-ce que tu
penses franchement que les femmes sont
incapables de faire un créneau
ça va mal se terminer comme ça je vais
dire
je vais si je te dis oui un petit peu
genre toutes les chaînes de garde au cul
de main j'en ai une qui va te rendre fou
est-ce que tu as déjà pensé le catogan
la mouche dans le lait
le soufflet au sultan
er
la mouche dans le lait j'adore ça la
mouche dans le lait c'est du Michel
Audiard
mais sérieux si notez malheureux ou pas
écoute oui évidemment j'avais pas faire
ça pendant 15 ans mais enfin j'aurais
bien fait encore une saison ou deux
quand même oui tu vois c'est sûr je
prends beaucoup de plaisir à faire cette
émission tu connais Laurent c'est
agréable d'être avec lui dire des
conneries
du grand public
une façon sporadique
[Musique]
la vérité on a un peu tristouille quand
même tu vois c'est normal tu fais pas ça
pendant 8 ans et à mon avis c'est en
septembre qu'on va flipper là on est
cassé on a envie de vacances et tout
mais en septembre
va commencer et puis qu'on va se
retrouver comme deux gars à l'école les
voitures plus d'essence la mousse dans
d'autres aventures nous attendent voilà
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire alors ou pas
Jean-Marie en 2004 je vais réussir un
exploit vous avez réuni 50000 personnes
au Stade de France la même année vous
avez été sacré comique préféré des
Français par l'Ifop devant Laurent Gerra
et Raymond Devos elle a tué d'ailleurs
vous avez vendu 3 millions du coffret
Bigard mais le paquet vous avez joué
Molière Le bourgeois gentilhomme sur
scène mise en scène par Linx avec de
bonnes critiques et des salles pleines
vous avez enchaîné sur un tournage
et vous revenez le 15 septembre avec un
nouveau spectacle absolument qu'elle
n'ya
je ne suis jamais viré car je suis mon
propre employeur
quand même parce que revenir en
septembre avec un oui je pensais pas que
le bourgeon ça allait être aussi crevant
et puis là j'ai ce petit film à tourner
maintenant j'ai encore deux sketchs à
faire avec le lot donc votre nouveau
spectateurs
[Rires]
votre nouveau spectacle
tu te souviens de ça voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même pas je sens pas Laurent mais
j'adore quand on me demande re demandez
moi encore
dans une nouvelle spectacle le nouveau
spectacle de Jean-Marie Bigard s'appelle
mon psy va mieux oui c'est
mieux c'est le théâtre comédien
donc vous racontez des histoires de psy
oui des histoires de dessus puis surtout
là ça va aller ça va aller très loin
parce que je raconte mes rêves et donc
les rêves ça n'a pas de limite donc ça
me permet de plein de trucs
justement je vais dire j'ai dit j'ai
rêvé arrête c'est ma promo Lolo York non
j'ai rêvé j'ai fait un cauchemar ignoble
je devais abattre tout mon troupeau de
chiens de garde tout ça parce qu'il y en
avait une qui avait un peu d'herpès sur
la lèvre inférieure droite
j'ai acheté des tubes et puis j'ai dû
être dénoncé par un voisin jaloux et
alors le pire dans dans mon rêve c'est
qu'il devait les abattre d'une balle
dans la chatte
et là faut être droit faut viser le
[__] sinon elle souffre pendant des
heures c'est assez mignon de prendre la
défense des chaînes de garde par exemple
je vais le voir trois fois par semaine
parce que il est pas bien il va me faire
une connerie
moi Jean-Marie
au début des années 90 tu as suivi
toi-même une thérapie de groupe non
absolument pour de vrai avec le docteur
jalanque absolument non non seulement je
l'ai fait mais dans ce spectacle je vais
faire faire une thérapie aux gens
c'est-à-dire ah bah oui il y a un test
il y a des tests de déprime par exemple
pour savoir si tu es déprimé ou pas je
vais poser des questions aux gens les
gens vont répondre par oui ou par non et
après je dirais tous ceux qui ont dit
oui à celle-là et celle-là ils sont pas
bien heureusement
par exemple si tout était à refaire tu
dirais oui ou non
depuis le début de l'émission depuis le
début de ma vie depuis le début de ta
vie je dirais non et ben donc c'est bien
tu es pas tu es pas
dépressifs
alors c'est des questions qui sont
planquées évidemment dans le
questionnaire chacun répond et tout donc
ça va être très interactif on sortira
pas indemne de mon spectacle c'est sûr
mais dis-moi la récitation de mantra et
la méditation te suffit pas tu es en
plus tu es obligé d'aller voir un psy
bah ouais bien sûr tu vas voir
non seulement c'est compatible mais la
psychanalyse qui est allé bien faite et
qu'elle fait qu'elle te permet de
t'approcher de toi te conduire vers la
méditation un manquablement un
manquablement parce que tu relativise
tout si tu es bien si tu as bien
travaillé sur toi tu risques plus la
grosse déprime ça existe plus tu
relativise quand te flatte par exemple
tu dis bon j'en prends pas trop quand je
suis dessus tu dis j'en prends pas trop
non plus tu restes au milieu tu
comprends tu prends plus les couilles la
voix du milieu d'où le nom d'où le nom
du milieu on va faire une interview si
comment allez-vous Jean-Marie Bigard
bien de temps en temps mais pas toujours
mais des fois c'est pas mal quand même
assez souvent mais c'est pas toujours de
quoi aimeriez-vous nous parler ce soir
et bien de mon prochain spectacle qui
s'appelle mon psy va mieux
aux comédien à partir du 15
si je vous demande de me raconter un
souvenir d'enfance n'importe lequel ce
serait quoi mon meilleur souvenir
d'enfance c'est la première fois que
qu'une fille m'a attrapé les roubignacs
j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire parce que
tu peux pas le raconter ça se décrit pas
je me suis dit si c'est ça la vie je
suis d'accord pour continuer c'est quoi
une expérience la plus traumatisante de
ta vie
de ma vie c'était de perdre mes parents
mais encore une fois j'ai analysé d'une
manière puisque c'est une interview psy
je pense que c'est les étages de de la
fusée qui se détache pour que la fusée
aille plus haut et après coup donc 30
ans plus tard je me dis mais si j'ai pas
perdu mais mes parents jamais je serais
monté à Paris jamais j'aurais connu
Laurent Baffie Thierry Ardisson tu vois
non mais c'est c'est tout à fait
un truc très important c'est que tout
arrive pour le mieux y compris le plus
gros des emmerdements tu as le choix ou
de l'accepter ou de renacler et tu peux
renacler toute ta vie quelque chose de
mauvais qui t'est arrivé ou alors tu
peux dire voilà une épreuve je la
franchis je suis digne de franchir
l'obstacle donc je le franchis dès
l'enfance vous avez besoin d'être aimé
je suis arrivé en costume ouais tous mes
frères et sœurs ils sont arrivés tout
tordus il a fallu tirer dessus et tout
moi je suis arrivé pas il a fallu tirer
sur le cordon pour pas que je me claque
dans le mur
enfin je suis arrivé j'ai fait et hop et
oui parce que j'étais le quatrième
j'étais pas tellement désiré donc je
suis arrivé en disant attendez mais je
t'ai pas tout de suite je suis drôle
c'est pour ça que je suis c'est pour ça
que je suis comique c'est pour ça aussi
que très souvent les artistes les grands
artistes les grands créateurs créateurs
ne sont presque jamais les premiers de
la famille parce que le premier tu le
bousille toujours un petit peu tu as
envie qu'il soit comme toi tu as envie
qu'il fasse pas les conneries que tu as
fait tu comprends donc le dernier comme
les trois autres d'avant ils ont déjà
bien déblayé le terrain le quatrième il
peut s'exprimer plus libre et ce besoin
de choquer tu l'expliques comment mais
va te faire [__]
non je n'ai pas besoin je ne je ne me
considère pas comme quelqu'un de
choquant non non si si à moins que
jamais torcher le cul d'un vieux à moins
qu'on ait jamais fait des trucs non non
qu'est-ce que vous avez encore du mal à
contrôler dans la vie
mes colères ouais vous êtes collés
l'injustice et la colère ça j'ai du mal
à régler le curseur
si j'ai eu envie de mourir Jean-Marie
j'ai tout le temps un petit peu envie ça
me plaît pas oui
la vérité comme je le dis dans mon
sketch j'ai vraiment pas peur de la mort
j'ai peur comme tout le monde de
souffrir que ça dure longtemps d'avoir
une déchéance tu vois longue et pénible
et tout mais sinon la mort si elle vient
aujourd'hui elle est elle est la
bienvenue le plus tard sera le mieux
parce que je suis pas suicidaire mais ça
me fait pas peur et elle vient quand
elle veut je l'attends c'est [__] là
qu'avez-vous en fin compris sur vous
j'ai compris que je n'étais que une
toute petite partie de l'univers qu'il
fallait pas trop s'affoler et que la vie
était vraiment un jeu et que le mieux
c'était de jouer encore
vous acceptez bien de ne pas avoir
d'enfant
bah je l'accepte en tout cas j'ai les
enfants des autres et puis d'avoir le
sien n'est jamais sûr que c'est le sien
ouais tu sais je vais dire un truc on
fera un contrôle sur le sur l'ensemble
de la planète on s'aper c'est vrai que
c'est pas c'est maman sûr papa peut-être
et puis on peut toujours adopter via les
enfants des autres il y a des filleuls
absolument par exemple tu as déjà été
tenté par une aventure avec un homme non
franchement non c'est un truc de c'est
c'est physique je suis pas je suis pas
contre des fois on s'embrasse quand on
fait les cons on s'embrasse sur la
bouche avec la langue on l'a fait un
coup tous les deux c'est attrait pour le
sexe la taille du sexe sur vos affiches
de spectacle etc ça trahi pas une
angoisse par rapport à la taille réelle
de votre sexe
c'était vraiment pour rigoler j'ai mis
des balles de tennis j'ai un sexe qui
est normal j'en suis assez content
si vous avez besoin de toucher les
couilles tout le temps Jean-Marie mais
pourquoi tu dis ça
boulevard de Sébastien
carte Fabrice Luchini vous devez placer
une citation de Louis Jouvet dans les
minutes qui suivent à tout de suite une
citation de Louis Jouvet regarde le
lustre et articule
à partir du 15 septembre au théâtre
comedia mesdames messieurs
Jean-Marie vous tournez là ouais je
retourne à Pontault-Combault et je
tourne dans une médiathèque car je suis
dans Mission je suis directeur d'une
médiathèque et ça se passe génialement
bien que une belle équipe de comédiens
bon courage j'y retourne maintenant
on se revoit je sais pas où mais on se
revoit on
se revoit
Charlotte Gainsbourg
je vais commencer Alain je sais pas si
on vous l'a déjà posé Thierry comment
vous savez tout ça
c'est tout con c'est parce que je
travaille
voilà mais comment vous savez tout ça
parce que les gens qui travaillent pour
moi sont très bons aussi ouais d'accord
[Applaudissements]
moi je veux bien savoir ce que tu penses
de toi
écoute je pense que j'ai pas encore fait
tout ce que j'avais à faire et que vous
avez pas fini d'entendre parler de
Thierry Ardisson
il est vraiment
une question pour Laurent Baffie Alain
j'ai une question d'intérêt général et
une question de zoologique est-ce que
vous préférez Laurent
est-ce que vous avez une théorie sur le
fait que le homard est un vieillissement
non j'ai pas de théorie là-dessus mais
je crois qu'on a beaucoup à découvrir du
homard il y a eu des traces écrites
quand on écrit par exemple Omar m'a tué
ça pose une vraie question
et je crois qu'on est au début des
connaissances sur le
très bien alors
ouais d'accord
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire le samedi
soir qu'est-ce que vous vous allez faire
le samedi soir ils vont reprendre une
vie normale ils vont se désacoutumer ils
vont refaire l'amour à leur femme ils
vont voilà quoi ils vont regarder
d'autres chaînes ou pas et peut-être le
meilleur conseil à donner aux gens ce
serait d'éteindre la télé de faire autre
chose que de regarder la télé puisque
maintenant il y aura plus rien de bien
programme qui va cartonner les gens
regarderont l'émission de Laurent
Ruquier qui sera à cet endroit là le
samedi soir
en rangeant les cassettes pour cette
dernière émission j'ai retrouvé un
souvenir qui n'a jamais rangé une
cassette de ta vie tu es un escroc total
dans tout le monde en parle et tous
ensemble vous connaissez le principe
attention c'est quoi 2 3
non non
ça ne peut pas marcher
1 2 3
Chantal Goya
qu'est-ce qu'il y a Laurent on me dit
qu'il faut tout refaire non
s'il y a une caméra qui sur Alain Chabat
si vous pouvez me filer la cassette
à ta famille parce que bien sûr parfois
tu déconnes mais parfois
[Musique]
vous êtes ici tous les deux ce soir pour
le nouveau film de Michel Gondry qui
s'appelle la science des rêves avec vous
il y a Gaëlle Garcia Bernal new Emma de
Caunes ça sort le 16 août Michel Gondry
c'est un réalisateur qui a commencé en
faisant des clips pour Bjork pour Daft
Punk et Isabelle Giordano juge les clips
de Michel Gondry assez farfelu
j'ai trouvé ça charmant
alors c'est un mec qui a fait donc des
clips ensuite il a fait human nature
éternel Sunshine enfin voilà Isabelle
Jordano trouve qu'il a un univers très
déjanté
voilà alors le pitch je fais le pitch
avec plaisir
alors le pitch c'est l'histoire de
Stéphane interprétée par Gaëlle Garcia
Bernal qui est timide qui est inhibé
dont la vie prend enfin un sens quand il
se laisse convaincre par sa mère de
retourner en France pays de son enfance
voilà mais il est très déçu par le
boulot soi-disant formidables qu'il
attend il bosse dans une entreprise de
calendrier
et il compense par ses rêves voilà et
devant des caméras en carton il
s'invente une émission de télévision sur
le sur le rêve un peu comme nous bientôt
alors Alain à vous le héros vous
rencontre dans l'entreprise de
calendrier vous devenez vous devenez
assez amis tous les deux et vous
Charlotte vous êtes la voisine dans le
héros tombe amoureux mais il finit par
vous faire peur quand même Stéphane au
bout d'un moment quand même
ouais mais on est assez similaire
alors on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
d'abord c'est assez étonnant ce film
c'est assez génial vous le connaissez le
principe 1 2 3 magnéto
c'est une histoire d'amour c'est une
histoire de rêve oh non c'est plutôt une
histoire de calendrier c'est une
histoire
[Musique]
Stéphanie Stéphane Stéphanie clic-clac
Stéphanie c'est la voisine Stéphanie
elle est belle
elle fait des choses avec ses mains
je sors avec eux c'est quoi je te couvre
une dernière fois mais si tu l'as pas je
te parle plus si jamais de ma vie
sur la bouche avec la langue
tu vois
ce n'est pas une histoire de sexe non
c'est une histoire d'amour comme ça on
va dans le passé et comme ça on va dans
le futur
mais qu'est-ce que c'est une machine
elle est objective ce n'est qu'une
machine c'est une histoire de rêve non
c'est un rêve qui raconte un rêve en
rêve
il a 6 ans il a ses épisodes d'inversion
en réalité
en fait c'est plutôt une histoire de
calendrier qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
maquettiste de calendrier promotionnel
c'est quoi exactement
le calendrier se compose de deux parties
le bas avec les mois et les filles
toutes nues le sac que c'est mortel
c'est tout tu vois une rousse avec un
gros buisson nous on s'occupe du haut la
partie gonflante c'est-à-dire le nom du
crétin qui m'a envoyé ce calendrier
stupide et ringard à ses clients en fin
d'année
ah non je suis pas d'accord un film de
skieur enfin moi je n'aime pas de taux
de ski
non c'est plutôt une histoire de rêve et
un cheval et il y a des volcans
sorti le 16 août 2006 madame monsieur
c'est un beau film qui qui fait qu'on se
sent bien en sorte
vous avez trouvé la meilleure définition
du film pour moi vous dites Gondry
raconte des trucs qui sont a priori pas
grave mais de manière très grave comme
des enfants
plus courtes
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un de très original donc le
film devient le film est très original
alors le 1er novembre il y a un autre
film où vous êtes ensemble une comédie
romantique qui s'appelle prête-moi ta
main d'Éric lartigault j'ai laissé faire
le pitch c'est l'histoire d'un
de Luis que je joue qui est entouré de
sa maman et de ses cinq soeurs qui est
donc très
très étoffé merci
et ils mettent une pression elle lui met
une pression terrible pour qu'il se
marie et décide de en fait de les faire
rencontrer une fille voilà j'ai fini
toutes les phrases
il décide de louer une femme une femme
une femme
pour les pose disons pour la présenter
plutôt à ses parents à sa famille enfin
vu d'un mariage quand même oui parce que
c'est intéressant c'est qu'en fait il se
dit lui il n'en peux pas dire la fin oui
mais quand même juste le début pour
aller chez il se dit je vais la
présenter ma famille ça va se passer
très bien elles vont elles vont l'adorer
on va annoncer notre mariage et en fait
elle viendra pas au mariage et je vais
tomber dans une profonde dépression et
plus personne ne me fâcher avec ces
histoires de mariage c'est son plan qui
va pas être du tout se passer quoi bien
sûr j'ai vu le film c'est vraiment très
drôle ça s'appelle prête-moi ta main ça
sort le 1er novembre je l'ai lu c'est
très bien et comme vous serez vous
n'êtes pas là à la rentrée si je peux
continuer sur ma promo de l'année parce
que j'aurais pu d'émission nous sortons
un DVD des nuls
ah c'est dommage c'était pratique aussi
pour ça cette émission
objectif nul en DVD voilà donc et puis
j'ai une Panda à vendre qui est
franchement qui est encore en très bon
état
vous êtes tout le temps ensemble à tous
les deux maintenant le film de gondré le
film de l'articot
er de quelque chose ils vont pouvoir au
bout d'un moment non
[Musique]
ah bon bah oui non alors en fait je
voulais je voulais vous la montrer pour
savoir comment elle était ah oui mais je
sais pas si on l'a pas ou pas tu veux
qu'on la passe je veux bien que vous la
regardiez juste pour me dire si ça va ou
si on change
maintenant c'est le travail d'une femme
de ta femme
j'ai trouvé le plan pour avoir la paix
pour moi je trouve une nana je la brief
présentation elle l'adore et on décide
de se marier
elle a trouvé du boulot assez
vous me prenez pour une [__] en gros je
propose de faire ma femme contre
rémunération ça n'a rien à voir avec
[__]
2400 et vous allez où là
je trouve que j'ai une vie aussi je suis
pas non plus dispo 24 heures sur 24
mettons-nous d'accord sur un nombre
d'heures par jour pour huit semaines une
journée de 8h normal avec pause déjeuner
15000 euros la semaine
15000 euros la semaine pour dire
rendez-vous avec ma famille et quatre
sourires au foutez de ma gueule quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien
moi j'aurais peut-être mis
c'est la dernière il a le droit je vais
avoir des vannes sur Ophélie Winter
Charlotte
à part qu'elle est bruyante et
je parle fort
je les trouve toutes les qualités
que j'ai trouvé sur internet
s'appelle quoi 5h55 c'est ça avec il y a
du monde
c'est très branché comme dirait Isabelle
Giordano
par le prisme d'Isabelle journaliste
cocker nickel good surface à quoi c'est
du beau monde
[Musique]
voilà Charlotte Gainsbourg
en exclusivité mondiale
ça s'appelle 5h55 ça sort le 28 août
voilà j'ai vachement bien tu vas faire
quelle émission alors pour en parler de
ton album
[Applaudissements]
et puis aussi une chose que je dois dire
c'est que le 30 juin donc elle a fait
des Loges le bracelet ah c'est
gentilation qui s'appelle l'étoile
enchantée très discret là-dessus l'idée
c'est d'emmener des films qui sont à
l'affiche dans les hôpitaux ou les
enfants sont hospitalisés à long terme
et de passer les films récents comme
voilà tous les films récents familiaux
et donc à la Fête des Loges les forains
donne pendant une journée la recette à
l'association il faut acheter un petit
bracelet coûte 15 euros et qui donne
droit à toutes les attractions voilà et
tous les manèges
c'est bien
j'ai vu des reportages sur cette
association dont vous occupez l'étoile
enchantée quand les enfants sont à
l'hosto malade et qu'on leur apporte les
films qui sont sortis une semaine avant
en salle c'est fabuleux même la semaine
de la semaine de sortie c'est vraiment
ils voient le voilà le cinéma c'est vrai
quand les enfants peuvent pas se
déplacer c'est au cinéma de se déplacer
quoi donc bravo c'est super
voilà ça va très discret
dans le câlin est tellement discret
qu'on va faire une interview la vérité
sur Alain Chabat
est-ce que oui ou non vous avez pécho
par ici le temps la semaine dernière à
Los Angeles
non j'étais à Tourcoing est-ce que oui
ou non vous a mis dans son CV à la
rubrique expérience professionnelle
non mais c'était une très bonne
est-ce que oui ou non vous avez perdu 10
kilos
non
est-ce que oui ou non vous êtes toujours
faim qui fraîche
oui je suis funky fresh je suis je j'ai
l'apparence comme ça d'un garçon un
petit peu un petit peu gros un petit peu
mais à l'intérieur je suis un grand noir
extrêmement musclé qui est très bien
est-ce que oui ou non vous êtes heureux
moins depuis que vous arrêtez mais sinon
oui
[Applaudissements]
parce que oui ou non vous êtes
devenu Hollywood
je suis j'essaye de d'importer la
merguez à Hollywood en ce moment je
travaille là-dessus je pense qu'il y a
un marché qui est intéressant est-ce que
vous venant depuis 5 ans vous pouvez
choper toutes les actrices françaises
que vous voulez à la
Charlotte
oui bien sûr est-ce que oui ou non
Dominique farroja vous surnomme le
serpent à lunettes oui mais il m'énerve
c'était mon surnom le serpent à lunettes
est-ce que oui ou non les nuls vont se
reformer un jour peut-être en tout cas
nous sortons un DVD
à la rentrée
est-ce que oui ou non Chantal lobby à
baiser avec un des nuls non et c'est pas
on a franchement on a essayé
on voulait rien savoir est-ce que ou non
canal est avant tout une aventure
humaine merveilleuse dans laquelle vous
avez vécu les plus belles années de
votre vie et qui vous a permis
d'accomplir vos rêves les plus fous
merci oui canal et avant tout une
aventure merveilleuse
dans laquelle j'ai pu accomplir mes
rêves les plus fous et je me souviens
plus bien du milieu de la phrase
rappelons que l'anagramme de Alain
Chabat donne habitat canal
j'ai trouvé ça en cherchant en rangeant
des cassettes je fais ça toute la
semaine Laurent est-ce que oui ou non
vous avez retrouvé l'esprit canal avec
Stéphane Bern à mort
est-ce que oui ou non vous la péter un
peu depuis Astérix je me la suis
toujours pété c'était avant Astérix
est-ce que oui ou non vous étiez un
danger pour le gouvernement et c'est
pour ça qu'on a essayé de descendre le
film des Robins
on peut rien dire là-dessus
non
est-ce que oui ou non vous pouvez faire
le chien là maintenant
[Musique]
il y a que trois
merci merci de dire qu'elles sont toutes
différentes parce que des fois nous
soutiennent cinq fois la même voilà
c'est exactement
qu'est-ce que c'est celle-là
vous devez annoncer votre séparation
avec Yvan Athan histoire de donner des
sujets d'articles magazine People
moi je peux parler tout doucement
donne-moi la 3e merci vous devez écorner
votre image de jeune fille classe et
tendance en vous mettant dans le doigt
dans le nez ça c'est facile
1 2 3 4
maintenant que je sais qu'elles sont
toutes différentes
cartes vous devez envoyer un texto à
Steven spielberge
Steven spielberge Spielberg Spielberg
ça ça va me manquer tu vois ça ce
pouvoir que j'ai de c'est d'arrêter
la sono quand tu fais le geste
[Musique]
je vais essayer
incroyable et Thierry ce que vous n'avez
pas essayé c'est avec les invités ah oui
Thierry ce que je pense qui est vraiment
intéressant
il y a tellement de mecs qui nous ont
gonflé avec lesquels on aurait pu faire
ça et bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
salut
je vous demande de vous arrêter
votre campus dans les plus rien à [__]
je sais que vous faites ça à tous les
invités
alors Jamel il y a un rituel pour cette
dernière émission c'est que les invités
quand ils arrivent doivent me poser une
question et poser une question à Laurent
Baffie
je t'écoute c'est quoi l'adresse des
chandelles exactes c'est rue Thérèse
cherchait cette adresse partout avec tu
laves
il faut que je pose aussi une question à
Laurent pourquoi tu assumes pas ta
calvitie j'ai jamais compris alors j'ai
beaucoup d'humour je veux pas qu'on
parle de ça je crois que c'est clair
il me la perche c'est pas bien
humainement c'est moche minute de bisous
comme dans
autre rituel dans cette émission on
s'encule
[Rires]
comme toi voilà alors autre rituel dans
cette émission en rangeant des cassettes
cette semaine j'ai retrouvé un souvenir
en Jamel Debbouze dans cette émission
le casting ce soir c'est un peu Arthur
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait on dit tous
ensemble 1 2 3
c'est moi qui le dis c'est pas vous non
c'est tout le monde maintenant si les
poules aussi les poux qui s'y cadent
elles ont dit c'est elle qui l'ont
faites pas le public comme je suis à la
place des poussettes attention ah deux
trois magnéto
il ne faut pas vendre la peau de l'ours
surtout si l'ours est dedans encore
on sait jamais
ça peut toucher parce que je peux faire
c'est Charles de Gaulle c'est son
aéroport
ça c'est sûr
depuis que je suis connu c'est plus
facile pour les autographes
le vrai problème du foulard à l'école
c'est surtout pour la piscine
ce qui est bien chez Ben Laden
[Applaudissements]
ce qui nous a fait préférer le train
bien sûr avec Ben Laden si possible si
jamais c'est s'arrête demain
ça sera à cause de toi
je vous demande de vous arrêter alors
Jamel j'ai vraiment
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir
l'autre était pas mieux non ça dépend
des invités c'est plus facile
ce soir pour une double actualité
d'abord le Jamel Comedy Club sur Canal+
et puis le film indigène et comme je
pense qu'on dit que les Arabes sont
feignants c'est énorme ce que vous
faites en une année de Chanel
alors Jamel Comedy Club très beau titre
d'abord très facile très simple on doit
j'en profite pour remercier Kader de
tout ce qu'il fait pour cette émission
depuis quatre ans voilà
salut Kader alors Jamel Comedy Club
Botti rémission diffusée tous les
samedis à 20h sur Canal+ à partir du 15
juillet une émission dans laquelle vous
donnez leur chance à de nouveaux comics
spécialisés dans le stand up exact c'est
comme le petit théâtre de Bouvard mais
on est en drôle quoi en plus funky
c'est bien cette chaîne Canal c'est
c'est
une chaîne qui permet de
qui laisse la place non c'est sûr que
moi d'ailleurs je remercie Canal+ pour
plein de trucs forcément
là on a été les voir avec ce concept ils
ont dit oui tout de suite j'avoue que ça
fait plaisir de travailler avec des gens
comme ça moi c'est une aventure humaine
formidable et c'est incroyable ce qui
était arrivé merci
alors le fils de cette émission on peut
dire qu'elle est basée sur le stand-up
un micro 4 artistes par émission qui
viennent faire cinq minutes de discours
moi c'est vrai que c'est Kader qui m'a
montré cette forme scénique je
connaissais pas le stand-up avant qu'il
m'en parle j'ai découvert Richard prior
Eddie Murphy Dave chapelle c'est des
mecs qui qui sont dans le plus simple
appareil ils arrivent ils ont un micro à
la main et ils racontent ce qu'ils ont
fait la veille c'est incroyable il donne
l'impression que c'est que tout le monde
peut le faire en fait c'est ça c'est
comme quand tu vois Zinédine Zidane dans
une phase de réparation tu as
l'impression que tout le monde peut
faire la roulette tu pourrais pas faire
la roulette Thierry c'est plus une prise
de parole en fait que des pitrories quoi
c'est vraiment un discours quoi c'est
une étude sociologique cette émission tu
vas voir on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble c'est mieux 1 2 3 magnéto
Serge alors Mesdames Messieurs
aujourd'hui on exclusivité mondiale je
vais vous présenter ce qui va être les
stars du stand up en France la relève
les filles écoutez-moi bien je vous
donne un conseil les hommes il faut les
pourchasser
parce que si tu ne rentres pas ton petit
popotin dans un jean Diesel tu pars avec
un sévère handicap et c'est de rentrer
ça dans un diesel
mais attendez parce que ça c'est rien
c'est rien parce que il y a des filles
qui sont tellement traînées qu'elles
arrivent à communiquer entre elles sans
bouger les lèvres et c'est très balèze
93 si vous voulez c'est le Bronx
français
et une personne qui se fait agresser
toutes les 7 minutes
cette personne c'est moi
et j'ai vu que des paléontologues
avaient découvert un squelette vieux de
3 millions d'années
et en analysant enfin ses cheveux ils
ont réussi à prouver qu'il était mort
d'une diarrhée sévère
et là je me suis dit effectivement si le
mec en avait jusque dans les cheveux
devait être vraiment sévère
ne lui hip-hop c'est devenu super gai
franchement lui hip hop c'est super gay
vous avez vu les clips de rap des mecs
balaise torse nu qui se met du mono sur
les tétons
et qui s'achètent des bijoux de quoi il
parle les rappeurs entre eux
j'adore ton dernier clip de boucles
d'oreilles en saphir trop belle ah ouais
t'as kiffé
mais c'est vrai que les Asiatiques sont
très à la mode ces derniers temps on l'a
vu avec les adoptions avec Johnny
Hallyday Angelina Jolie toujours des
petits asiatiques ouais toujours des
asiatiques des petits asiatiques
pourquoi toujours des petits asiatiques
moi j'ai la réponse quel gamin de moins
de 6 mois est capable de réparer ta
connexion internet en moins de 5 minutes
tu te rends compte tu te rends compte
les économies que tu fais en hotline
allô Club Internet wesh je t'emmerde moi
j'ai honte fou fou à la maison
c'est Bernadette Chirac qui me l'a
ramené elle a dû le prendre pour une
pièce jaune
les Noirs c'est un peu la dernière roue
du carence tu sais le le jour où Dieu a
créé les Noirs il a dû dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon alors les Noirs
la sécheresse tiens
les criquets
la famille
mettez-leur quand même une grosse [__]
[Applaudissements]
à 20h sur canal à partir du 15 juillet
madame monsieur et ça va déchiré
quel bonheur ils ont bien la pêche c'est
pour ça comment tu veux que j'en parle
faut regarder cette émission vaut
vraiment le coup les mecs ils ont tu
sais ce qui serait bien là en train
d'attendre que tu les fasses venir et
qu'on les voit là tout de suite là comme
ça
ça serait bien
si j'étais là
j'ai même soigner
on passe au blender
je vous présente le Comédie Club
présentez-vous les gens après les autres
commence par quoi
[Musique]
dictateur dans son pays c'est sûr je
pense voilà je suis du Cameroun c'est
bien ouais moi aussi on avait besoin
d'une blanche alors on a fait venir
blanche bien joué tu t'appelles comment
blanche ah oui blanche
[Applaudissements]
Fabrice pas de sonne jazz dodo qui boit
un litre de sang humain par jour
et Sami dit le compte de bouddha-bala
donc vous aurez le privilège de
retrouver cet été sur Canal+ j'espère
que vous serez nombreux à regarder cette
émission à vaut le coup
juste profiter de l'occasion c'est vrai
c'est la dernière tu m'as tu m'as
vraiment moi pour ma part en service
avec cette émission et je voulais vous
remercier tous les deux pour ça en fait
j'ai producteur de Jamel Comedy Club
mais aussi d'indigènes le film de Rachid
Bouchareb avec rush disais Sami Bouajila
Samy naceriez-vous sorti le 27 septembre
pour lequel vous avez eu tous un prix
d'interprétation collective au dernier
festival de Cannes
[Musique]
le film on en parlera quand il sortira
on en parlera la première de ta
prochaine émission par exemple 27 deal
ça réglé ouais 1 2 3
cette mission vous devez successivement
dire du bien de Laurent Gerra et du mal
du mal de Zinedine Zidane
Zidane
pourquoi pas manger du porc pendant
qu'on y est
juste vous dire que ces gens ont
énormément de talents
Zidane du stand-up c'est sûr et certain
et qui a un nouveau une espèce de
nouvelle mouvance au même titre que le
smurf ou hip-hop quand il est arrivé en
France j'ai l'impression que de plus en
plus il y a des petits lascars et des
petites tetés qui de plus en plus
trop dans l'intérêt à cet art parce que
c'est vraiment un truc spécifique le
stand-up et et il y a de plus en plus de
jeunes qui s'y intéressent il y a un
vrai mouvement quoi tu vois j'ai j'ai
quand je disais que c'était une étude
sociologique c'est pas loin
ça me rappelle le hip-hop quand ça
arrive en France au départ il y a un
engouement autour de ce truc et je
trouve ça formidable plus on est de fous
plus on rit j'encourage le maximum de
jeunes on les envoyer des des cassettes
n'hésitez pas à vous faire connaître
ça s'est passé un peu de la même manière
avec tout le monde ça s'est fait par
hasard pour la plupart d'entre eux et le
hasard fait bien les choses je suis
content
[Applaudissements]
comment sortir de 10h à partir du mois
de septembre Fabrice Subway vous voyez
là au théâtre de 10h à partir du mois de
septembre et pas de ça il y a moi
phénomène qui existe au mois de
septembre
merci d'avoir été avec nous mes amis
au revoir
Michel Bernier Gérard Darmon il va
attendre
[Musique]
ici ce soir pour son nouveau disque
on peut faire sortir toutes ces stars
qui attendent
un peu moins de charme
donc ils vont on va commencer par toi
une question à moi une question à
Laurent
alors moi je voudrais savoir après
toutes ces années ouais des missions je
viens ici que je reste tard le soir
alors que je travaille le lendemain
matin que je bouffe des sushis chauds
dans la loge
jamais quand j'ai regardé ton émission
j'ai vu ma petite tête au générique
alors que ils sont tous au générique et
que moi j'ai jamais été au générique
alors je voudrais savoir une bonne fois
pour toute si tu m'aimes mais oui tu
sais bien que je t'aime moi aussi
je t'aime en plus
une question alors est-ce que tu m'aimes
beaucoup
à la bouche par la bouche
est-ce que tu peux poser la question à
Charlotte alors maintenant on continue
avec toi va bouger
alors Gérard une question à moi une
question à Laurent Baffie
je préfère le bonheur ou la vérité c'est
un thème de la vérité la vérité la
vérité bien une question à Laurent
après les clés de bagnole
et bien j'ai racheté les droits des
intergos de Marcel Pagnol et je vais
expliquer son oeuvre je vais appeler ça
les clés de Pagnol ce sera un film
magnifique et je travaille sur Sagnol un
footballeur
Michel Bernier une question à moi une
question alors
oui parce que moi je suis voilà
Thierry quand on est royaliste catho
comment est-ce qu'on peut être aussi
immoral que toi d'abord royaliste je
suis monarchiste constitutionnelle comme
en Angleterre comme en Espagne comme en
Suède comment Norvège comme au Danemark
comment Hollande on sait rien
extraordinaire sauf pour les Français
voilà et d'une et deuxièmement catho
c'est aimez-vous les uns les autres
merci donc j'aime mon prochain tant
mieux
alors est-ce que tu t'es déjà emmerdé
pendant cette émission oh que oui et des
nombres incalculables de fois on en a eu
du sueur et du lourd on en a eu des
fêtes couilles on enlève des boulets des
punitions des fats oui je me suis aussi
je voulais juste dire un truc sur le
Gérard il est vraiment maman
cette semaine en rangeant des cassettes
j'ai retrouvé des vieilles cassettes de
l'émission que j'ai visionné
c'est un peu Arthur ouais bah oui j'ai
trouvé un extrait extraordinaire avec
Yvan Attal et on va tous dire ensemble 1
2 3
alors Jane comment ça va bien
la longueur il y a très peu de questions
en même temps vous l'avez vu le dernier
film vivant bien sûr j'ai vu le dernier
film de
dans
vous pensez quoi de votre beau-fils
vous la trouvez vous la trouvez heureuse
Charlotte avec Yvan la jamais été aussi
heureuse
dites-moi Jane votre accent
c'est du pipeau non évidemment
il est plus que bon il est vraiment
alors cette semaine toujours en journée
cassettes je vais retrouver des images
de toi je sais pas comment tu viens
jamais dans cette émission je comprends
pas c'est vrai qu'on a très peu
c'est rare 1 2
[Applaudissements]
la taille de quoi
après il y a une autre question qui est
taille du sexe c'est à part là c'est
taille 80 le poids
75 si vous Bruno j'ai perdu 15 kilos
vous êtes vraiment vraiment pas mal un
concert
vos films c'est marrant parce que je
trouve meilleur depuis que vous avez
changé de lunettes c'est parce que vous
vous lisez les scénarios maintenant
maintenant
il fallait d'abord apprendre le oui
c'est ça il faut la prendre à lire
et maintenant c'est comme ça qu'on fait
le cœur des hommes c'est l'année
prochaine il les comprend et encore
tirer la langue et faire ah
oui bien sûr
elle est pas trop chargée ce soir ça va
elle est bien rose aujourd'hui
d'habitude elle est jaune gris tu vois
la taille du sexe Gérard je sais que
c'est une question qui vous obsède un
petit peu tout à l'heure
Michel j'ai retrouvé aussi des images de
vous vous en doutez parce que je suis
jamais venue dans cette émission
vous venez pour la version de du démon
de midi en SMS non
j'ai fait les poupées maintenant
bon attention 1 2 3
Michel Bernier est-ce qu'on peut dire
que ce film c'est d'abord une rencontre
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est d'abord
la rencontre avec une histoire la
rencontre avec un réalisateur ou
simplement la rencontre d'un personnage
je pense c'est d'abord avec un
réalisateur parce que depuis que je suis
actrice
j'arrête de tourner avec Claude Lelouch
et enfin ça y est
[Musique]
Michel pour vous c'est le film de la
maturité
je dirais de ma première et seconde
jeunesse car je suis éternelle
de cinéma c'est du rêve en 24 images
seconde Michel non
alors Michel vous êtes ici ce soir aussi
pour arrête de pleurer Pénélope 2
en tant que metteur en scène en tant que
metteur en scène en septembre et une
autre pièce en tant qu'actrice qui
s'appelle dolorescléborne de Stephen
King mise en scène 2
Marie Pascal austéritz un jour tu y
arriveras je te jure je suis pas sûr d'y
arriver que vous interprétez en
septembre donc ça fait deux petites
mains
j'ai pas compris un truc c'est la
dernière dernière
qu'est-ce que tu fais du du décor après
écoute alors Denis Arcan veut tourner
dedans donc on va le garder on va le
stocker pour les prochains films de
Denis Arcan voilà mais parce que comme
c'est toutes les dernières
normalement c'est
des trucs
je vous laisse finir votre interview
tout ça et de temps en temps je
repasserai
donc Michel deux promos ça fait deux
petites pommes attention vous êtes prêt
1 2 3 Laurent
alors le démon de midi 2 non c'est pas
ça
[Rires]
c'est bon c'est bon à partir du 22
septembre vous êtes sur la scène du
Théâtre des Bouffes Parisiens dans
Dolores kleborn donc de Stephen King or
le pitch c'est une vieille dame qui
meurt dans des circonstances suspectes
en laissant sa fortune à sa gouvernante
de le reste les bornes que la police
soupçonne demeure et pour s'innocenter
Dolores va devoir raconter toute
l'histoire en fait voilà elle va
raconter comment ça s'est passé avec
cette vieille das que est-ce que est-ce
que c'est du polar c'est du Stephen
Kingo c'est c'est du drame du cynisme la
méchanceté de la folie voilà et c'est
surtout l'histoire d'une femme pour moi
exceptionnelle puisque elle a cette
phrase que j'adore c'est quelquefois
pour s'en sortir et pour survivre une
femme n'a pas d'autre choix que d'être
une [__] et quand on quand on voit
l'histoire après on comprend ce qu'elle
veut dire ouais voilà c'est un
personnage fort intelligent humain et
drôle aussi c'est la première fois que
vous allez jouer vraiment une pièce
sérieuse au Théâtre Michel non et oui je
me lance je prends des risques
oui toujours
Marie Pascal il y a toujours Marie
Pascal bah oui parce que c'est mon alter
ego c'est mon ange gardien
austerite c'est belge
[Musique]
alors Michel vous êtes venu ici très
souvent on croit vous connaître en fait
je suis sûr quand vous connaissez pas
très bien mais personne ne sait qui je
suis
je ne suis pas seul que vous croyez
Michel comment ne voulez-vous surtout
pas qu'on vous appelle et
toi ça me gave ça c'est bon
quel genre de femme êtes-vous pas
une femme d'affaires
quel défaut que vous n'avez pas
je suis hélas pas assez radine ah quelle
question me faut-il surtout pas vous
poser Michel
tu veux une rose tu sais dans les
restaurants là qui arrive avec son
bouquet
et le mec il te dit tu en veux une là
quel moment de votre vie ne faut-il pas
aborder samedi dernier
qu'est-ce qu'il ne faut surtout pas dire
à propos de votre pièce qui c'est qui à
la fin qu'est-ce qu'il faut surtout pas
vous demander de faire du sport
qu'est-ce qu'un homme ne devrait surtout
pas faire pour vous séduire bah me
présenter sa femme
à quelle actrice quand vous compare
à l'actrice qui a fait la fidèle la
chienne là
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous voulez surtout pas
qu'on dise après cette émission Michel
on était encore là
alors alors
à la rentrée quel film tu ne viendras
pas présenter chez tout le monde en fait
parce que pour la première fois de ma
vie j'ai enchaîné deux films j'ai fait
un thriller d'un type qui s'appelle Éric
Barbier un film très noir qui a fait le
brasier exactement et je suis en train
de tourner un film de Nils sur un jeune
candidat qui se présente à des élections
et qui se prépare pour un grand débat
pendant une semaine avec tout son staff
qui s'occupe de son image sa
communication etc voilà donc j'avais
deux films qu'on va rater quoi
s'arrêter de tourner quand même
[Musique]
et toi alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a quel
film ou qu'elle dise tu ne viendras pas
vendre ici et ben l'album que je suis en
train de faire le deuxième qui sort
quand en septembre
[Musique]
mon amour
Geneviève de Fontenay
quel bonheur de vous avoir tous ici ce
soir pour cette dernière émission
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors j'aime bien
je me rappelle j'ai dû venir la première
fois en 98 quelque chose comme ça 1900
que je te remercie parce que je crois
que tu as contribué à la popularité que
j'ai maintenant
tout est possible
c'était logique de sa part que de parler
à l'accident
[Musique]
non on a passé des bons moments ensemble
est-ce que tu te rappelles le petit mot
que tu m'avais mis un jour dans ma loge
je t'aime en secret voilà il m'avait dit
Geneviève je t'aime en secret
et en ce qui concerne Thierry je te
remercie parce que tu nous a toujours
accueilli j'ai eu ma réva encore il y a
quelques temps superbe il y a un truc
que j'ai jamais fait oh non non non
quand même pas
maintenant Benoît XVI
j'avais promis qu'il vienne
dans cette dernière émission c'est que
les invités posent une question à
Laurent et à moi en commençant par moi
c'est normal je t'écoute Geneviève
j'ai pas tellement de questions à te
poser j'étais venu pour te remercier
avant tout pose-moi une question c'est
le moment ou jamais est-ce que tu
m'aimes oui je te bats
peut-être chaude
non je suis je suis très touché ce soir
tu vois vraiment
c'est vrai
je vais je vais commenter l'élection de
Miss Univers sur Paris Première sur
Paris
une question à Thierry Ardisson une
question alors
un peu de temps pour trouver ma question
c'est lui qui pose la question
quelle est la Miss France qui t'a le
plus marqué
Elodie Gossuin parce qu'elle a des
couilles
quel animal
[Rires]
quel animal est petit à des ailes avec
des petites plumes et vol comment
s'appelle-t-il
j'ai envie de dire
je pensais
on passe au blind test je vous demande
de vous arrêter
alors en rangeant des cassettes cette
semaine
j'ai retrouvé des images de toi
complètement par hasard on va les voir
mais avant 1 2 3 4
ça va plutôt pas mal enfin c'est-à-dire
que ça pourrait aller mieux mais [__]
vous êtes fort ça va quand même pas mal
bon vous leur dites quoi au ménagères de
moins de 50 ans quand vous les draguer
dans les supermarchés Franck je leur dis
que je les emmerde
Eddy lequel de vous fera un bon film en
premier je crois que attendez
[Applaudissements]
c'est évident que c'est moi vous êtes
d'accord avec ça Élie vous pensez ça
vous êtes en tournée avec votre
spectacle et lycée
[Applaudissements]
excusez-nous de vous avoir dérangé
de la redevance
une pensée pour tous les intermittents
qui n'ont pas fait leur 507 heures
[Musique]
je pourrais te chanter
pour me quitter Carlos
c'est gentil ah c'est gentil merci
Monsieur Debbouze
c'est très bien
et excusez-moi de vous avoir dérangé
dans cette émission tout le monde tout
le monde a son jingle c'est la bonne
racaille ça hein
Ellie vous êtes en tournée avec votre
spectacle Élie Semoun se prend pour qui
et vous serez du 22 septembre 10 octobre
ou à l'Olympia bien sûr bien sûr un
grand classique que je dirais vous aurez
pu faire tout le monde en parle début
septembre
alors c'est pour ça
bonne santé monsieur de Caroline
[Applaudissements]
extraordinaire dans votre spectacle
c'est votre capacité à interpréter
successivement des personnages très
différents les uns des autres par
rapport à Gérard qui ne sait jouer qu'un
rôle
on assiste tout le temps que vous avez
dit sérieusement vous avez dit comme
Clara Morgane il y a plusieurs personnes
en moi j'ai dit ça
très joli ça c'est moche l'attitude que
Tom enfin bon c'est vrai que c'est le
seul point commun que je peux avoir avec
elle et au niveau du plaisir c'est le
même voilà tout à fait sauf que elle oui
mais moi je fais l'amour avec 2000
personnes tous les soirs elle je sais
pas peut-être pas 2000 sauf l'été au Cap
d'Agde peut-être il y a un personnage
que j'adore c'est Kevina
on va faire une interview Kevin à
salut Kevin salut ça va
ça te dérange pas si je te tutoie que
Vina non ça va quasiment là
tu sais que tu as une grosse poitrine
pour ton âge se trouve
bien et ça fait quel âge maintenant
dans quatre ans j'aurai 20 ans
je suis en scène 2 parce que j'ai
redoublé trois fois le CE2 si mes
parents considèrent que je suis trop mûr
et tu écoutes quoi comme musique en ce
moment
je télécharge tout sur internet alors je
sais pas trop
et dis-moi Kevin a été aller voir le
dernier concert de Justin Timberlake à
Paris
mais j'ai une copine qui a été elle a
enregistré tout le concert son téléphone
parce qu'elle a un forfait Neo
être une star
tu t'intéresses à la politique kevinard
ouais je disais je pense que l'année
prochaine je voterai pour
pour Nicolas royal et Ségolène Ségolène
Sarkozy je sais pas
si j'entends bien que tu es vieux
ouais je maintiens bien je maintiens
bien avec ma mère mais mon beau-père
c'est un connard
Ellie Semoun tu l'aimes bien il Semoun
ouais j'aime bien j'aime bien son humour
j'aime bien disons pour moi c'est le
meilleur comique de cette génération
et Franck Dubosc tu l'aimes bien Bundy
boss
il ressemble à Alain Delon mais en plus
vieux
et tu crois que sans ces lentilles
bleues il aurait fait la même carrière
Franck Dubos
tu as changé de mec CAD ah non non
[Applaudissements]
il t'a amené dîner Ton Jules pour la
Saint-Valentin Kevin
au McDo
vous vous embrassez sur la bouche avec
ton mec ou non on se fait juste des
snacks
avec mon chien
et vous vous avez jamais couché ensemble
en fait non je couche qu'avec mes
peluches pour l'instant
et ça fait quoi d'apprendre que Britney
Spears c'était maman Kevina
qu'est-ce que tu fais après l'émission
Kevin à je rentre chez moi pourquoi tu
as quelque chose à me proposer
[Musique]
Geneviève en rangeant des cassettes
cette semaine des vieilles et 7 j'ai
trouvé des trucs incroyables quand tu
étais là ouais tu veux regarder
à poil sérieux mais c'est pas le
problème c'est pas le problème
[Musique]
vous remercions de cette chance
incroyable que nous allons faire de
devenir célèbre 24 heures
j'aime bien j'aime bien ah c'est pas moi
j'aime bien
j'aime bien non j'aime bien j'aime bien
je suis désolé j'aime bien j'aime bien
je suis désolé
je le ferai plus
jamais
sur notre devant mon épouse de toi plus
de Pan et du côté un amour j'aime bien
cette séquence
[Applaudissements]
et c'est toi bonsoir
carte interdiction vous êtes interdit
des missions avec cartes pendant un an
c'est pas possible c'est impossible
c'est impossible on est dedans
[Applaudissements]
ça va il vient il vient de tirer une
carte où il est interdit d'Arthur
pendant un an et pour lui c'est pas
possible on a tourné lundi l'émission
durant la rentrée ah vous avez une
émission à la rentrée monsieur
de la base je vous rappelle tout à
l'heure
bon ce qu'on va faire genevièvement je
vais te laisser aller te changer parce
que tu es couverte de champagne
et puis après bah vous revenez pour le
blind test hein
je cache le téléphone
c'est la mienne c'est ça
l'a déjà vu
Charlotte Alain Gérard Michel
Geneviève Élie Thierry Françoise
on se casse dégager d'ici là
merci merci beaucoup
j'accueillaise Yann Foly Arthur
d'animaux et Jean-Louis Aubert
Jean-Louis Aubert
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon fils c'est mon fils
Gaston Gaston c'est Gaston
qu'est-ce que je peux faire le petit en
rouge c'est mon fils te pousserai tous
en pension à la date je vais dire qu'il
va aller dans un collège en Suisse mais
ça va être Mickey
maintenant
comment ça va ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est champagne de France 2
alors vous connaissez le principe de
cette dernière émission donc les invités
doivent me poser
premier principe l'année dernière
deuxième principe donc les invités
doivent me poser à moi et à Laurent une
question donc on va y aller en avant on
va commencer avec toi qui a l'habitude
de la télévision
[Musique]
est-ce que tu es jaloux Thierry avec ma
femme tu veux dire
mon épouse est venu tu l'embrassé sur la
bouche et je regarde un souvenir un
périssable alors ma deuxième question
c'est ce que ta femme est là ce soir oui
bonjour
Spider-Man
[Musique]
je vous présente Béatrice
bon ça y est ça c'était
[Musique]
en tout cas la mienne n'a pas mis la
langue
une question Laurent Baffie ce que tu es
jaloux
[Musique]
qui avez-vous regretté sur le plateau
j'ai invité un connard j'en suis désolé
voilà mais en 20 ans de carrière
enfin les pièces
à quand une émission tout seul quand
même pas toujours accompagnée
car elle va pas enfin pouvoir faire
l'amour le samedi soir
est-ce que tu te rappelles que c'est moi
qui t'ai fait changer de coiffure c'est
vrai tu es venu un soir ici exactement
je suis passé et j'étais à la j'étais au
maquillage avec le coiffeur je dis mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette coupe
j'avais la raison
la répatrice Duhamel la rime et toi
jusque dans le bas du dos
et là grâce à toi c'est vrai alors
est-ce que ça a changé ta vie tu as
relancé ma carrière
comme lui quand il a changé sa coiffure
aussi
est-ce que tu peux nous dire une de tes
meilleures vannes que tu as fait de ta
meilleure souvenir de vannes de
l'émission ou de un de l'émission on va
peut-être Nadine de Rothschild peut-être
est-ce que ça c'est trompé
de rire il y avait un mec complètement
allumé qui était là j'étais assis à côté
de lui et 20 minutes pour venir il a mis
20 minutes pour venir il était
complètement défait et tu lui as dit je
veux je veux la même chose
c'est très drôle c'était l'écrivain de
bec BD libérative
c'est mon fond de commerce vous êtes en
train de marcher sur mes placements
Thierry je sais pas si tu te souviens
pendant ton dîner
quel tu nous avais conviés on était tous
ensemble
non c'est juste qu'à un moment donné tu
as tu nous as donné comme pas un scoop
mais une envie très forte de faire du
cinéma et que tu avais l'idée à cette
époque là ça fait quelques mois déjà
d'un scénario qui trottait dans la tête
et tu me disais j'ose pas je sais pas
alors je voudrais te poser la question
est-ce que tu as avancé sur ton histoire
est-ce que tu es toujours est-ce que tu
vas un jour nous faire un très beau film
écoute je fais tout pour en tous les cas
merci
une question pour Laurent bafiliane
alors moi je voudrais poser à l'orange
et chercher des questions sur les
animaux mais il va tout savoir alors je
voudrais juste savoir pendant la pause
rose est-ce que tu es pas jaloux de
Thierry non je le vois embrasser ces
hommes ces femmes ses enfants parfois
des des gens mineurs jamais de problème
non non je suis admiratif non non tu
voudrais pas un petit bisou toi avec la
langue ou pas
qui va balancer la musique et tout voilà
bah il y a pas il y a pas d'enseignement
t'as vu il est sérieux hein tu vois je
n'aurais pas fait par respect nous
sommes pas libre tous les deux c'est ça
le problème
pose-moi une question moi je voudrais
que tu faire un petit blind test puisque
tu joues jamais ouais donc je peux le
faire avec la voix quoi je te fais des
tonton
difficile
le groupe
Iron Butterfly
voilà voilà
ça fait ma soirée
une question alors
là je vais faire baisser l'audiment dans
le cèdre en face de chez moi il y a un
oiseau qui chante le soir en regardant
le coucher du soleil et le matin il est
plus gros qu'un rouge-gorge mais il a la
gorge tout rouge il fait des traits il
imite tous les autres oiseaux ils
discutent avec tout le monde très bon
musicien qu'est-ce que ça peut être à
ton avis
alors justement Jean-Louis en rangeant
des cassettes cette semaine j'ai
retrouvé un passage de toi dans tout le
monde en parle énorme attention vous
êtes prêts les enfants 1 2 3 magnet
toi heureux moi heureux
alors évite de développer
Jean-Louis toi payer trop impôts
Jean-Louis parfois toi fidèle moins
fidèle oh tu tapes à dire ça moi
je suis infirmé-galles toi avoir gros
sexe moi avoir non pas grosse
moi aimer beaucoup ma fille nous pas
même tribu et lui venir en ami ah
d'accord
de feu et fumer
[Applaudissements]
alors toi aussi je l'ai retrouvé j'ai
retrouvé quelque chose en rangeant des
cassettes et oui 1 2 3
comment s'appelle coucou
Sylvie Vartan
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je suis obligé de prendre un
micro il marche encore
ce n'est pas toi
alors dans ton spectacle actuellement
d'ailleurs tu tu mêles les chansons et
les et les imitations maintenant oui
c'est un spectacle entrecoupé c'est un
peu un tarta une bonne parce que c'est
des sketches et des imitations tout le
long
et tu chantes
le soleil
il a trouve si jolie
dans ses branches elle a dit
lève quand il rougit avant
s'endormir liane
alors tu en as tourné Yann
fait le Casino de Paris plusieurs fois
et là je fais le Grand Rex le 18
novembre
alors Dany
j'en ai cassette j'ai trouvé quelque
chose de très sympa avec toi aussi
attention 1 2 3
[__] dure c'est beaucoup plus violent
que que [__] douce c'est l'intrusion
de de Bertrand Blier qui fait ça c'est
beaucoup moins sympa Dany Boon vous êtes
né le 26 juin 66 à Armentières non mais
c'est un peu c'est un peu quand même là
collision entre la folie douce de Lyon
et la folie dure de
manchots
ça me fait plaisir que vous me posiez
cette question
Laurent parce que justement ça va se
faire là maintenant
je te connais je te connais tellement
bien que j'étais sûr qu'on te disant
c'est vrai tu sors on a vu la question
en 1989 vous montez à Paris
où je faisais pas de télérégionale et
non mais c'est vrai que les sujets
abordés sont face à la montée
la première fois que vous jouez des
homosexuels oui comme ça oui moi j'ai
fait une fois avec
merci de passer dans notre belle région
voilà
c'est fini et alors toi aussi j'ai
retrouvé un truc très drôle c'est la
Biennale des Antiquaires tu t'en
souviens la Biennale des Antiquaires
avec Bernadette ah oui oui
1 2 3
en tous les cas Arthur à la Biennale des
Antiquaires vous étiez la table de
Bernard Arnault et Bernadette Chirac
extraordinaire
en France se retrouve lors de la
l'inauguration de la plus grande bielle
des antiquaires à table avec Bernadette
Chirac et qui avait 800 personnes et
tout et on m'assoit mais à l'opposé de
madame la Présidente parce que les mecs
ils disent faut pas qu'ils nous fassent
une boulette et en plein repas elle me
fait signe et elle me demande de venir
s'asseoir à côté
et c'était l'époque de la Ferme
célébrité et elle m'a dit vous
connaissez les producteurs de la ferme
parce que je n'aime pas du tout cette
émission je dis mais pas du tout je ne
les connais pas
et elle était très mignonne parce que un
moment tout le monde nous regardait et
j'ai dit elle me dit vous avez vu tout
le monde me regarde et j'ai fait une
vanne mais foireuse je dis parce que
tout le monde essaye de savoir qui est
la blonde à côté de moi et elle
n'apparaît
un grand moment de solitude
à mon avis elle regarde l'émission
puisque elle est venue voir le spectacle
d'hiver alors justement bonne
enchaînement tu es un vrai pro tu
enchaînes sur ta promo et voilà c'est
pour ça qu'on m'a pas viré moi et voilà
dans le quartier en vrai tourné en
France et au gymnase le 18 janvier à
partir du 18 janvier voilà ça laisse
largement le temps aujourd'hui d'acheter
des places mais oui c'est c'est
formidable j'ai découvert ce théâtre il
y a quelques années j'ai vu Dany jouer
la vie de chantier de nuit c'est bon pas
dans le spectacle avec Gad et voilà
c'est un rêve qui se poursuit
ouais c'est génial je suis heureux voilà
et je suis ça m'arrache le cœur de te le
dire mais tu m'as porté chance parce que
voilà
d'ailleurs je suis très anxieux pour le
gymnase c'est comment on va faire
exactement sur Canal+ c'est bien c'est
bien c'est une bonne chaîne c'est sympa
[Applaudissements]
alors
après
c'est important d'être là
beaucoup de comics ne viennent pas les
gens sont déçus
à frontières il y a avatar
à la rentrée alors frontière c'est quoi
le pitch
je dirais c'est du 100% rage une famille
de fou
qui vit à la frontière et qui vont
accueillir malheureusement un groupe de
jeunes délinquants qui arrivent de Paris
et je pense que il fallait voilà c'était
leur dernier stock et avatar c'est le
film de Julien Leclerc avec Albert
Tchiki kARIO Mélanie Thierry et on
commence le tournage à la rentrée vous
êtes bien tous les deux vous êtes
arrivés à basculer vos carrières
simultanément et elle déchire ma femme
aussi
pour une fois qu'on sait que c'est la
première fois qu'on vient à la télé tous
les deux
bisous pose bisous
de frontière attention 1 2 3
[Musique]
il faut connaître c'est quand tu fais
des films tu te mets en danger quand
même complètement ouais
je suis contente merci beaucoup merci
pour transmettre le message d'un ami de
la maison qui ne peut pas être là ce
soir
il est en cours il est en cours il peut
pas être avec nous parce qu'il est en
cours attention c'est Orlando 1 2 3
magnet
ça y est je suis au chômage
Jerry s'en va tout le monde en parfait
se porte qui va exiger l'équipe qui va
dire manitos Serge
je ne suis pas à Paris mais je voulais
te dire mon chéri combien j'étais ravi
de faire partie même indirectement de
cette belle aventure merci pour le
bonheur que tu nous as donné le samedi
pendant tant d'années merci d'être toi
ne change pas en thème comme tu es ce
soir pour ta dernière je ne veux pas
exiger le clip mais je vais exiger par
contre que tout le monde se lève pour
l'instant de gauvosh pour un triomphe et
te faire un triomphe bien mérité et te
dire à bientôt Thierry et bonnes
vacances allez tout le monde se lève
merci Orlando merci au revoir
le renard a bougé c'était très furté
mais le renard n'est pas décédé est-ce
que parce que tout le monde dit magnéto
Serge est-ce que on l'a dit j'ai vu
[Musique]
ouais bravo bravo
la dernière alors
quand est-ce qu'on le verrait alors quoi
cachés
[Applaudissements]
au début
il y a mon ailleurs
à quoi ça ressemble on va tous dire en
même temps 1 2 3 magnétos Serge il y a
un monde ailleurs
[Musique]
un monde ailleurs Jean-Louis Aubert
ailleurs
standard
alors Idéal Standard même vous vous
savez pas pourquoi vous avez pris steam
il est bien il est très bien c'est très
bien et très bien pensez que tout le
monde a un idéal standard en ce moment
quoi c'est ça non il faut pas en avoir
mais un petit idéal minimum moi quelque
chose de simple quelque chose d'amoureux
de facile donc l'idéal standard c'est
désormais dédié à votre ami d'enfance
Olivier Caudron alias olive de Lily drop
qui est mort en janvier dernier de la
tuberculose avec qui vous étiez allé
voir les où au Théâtre des
Champs-Élysées 69 voilà avec qui j'ai
traversé les États-Unis en stock avec
qui avec qui j'ai commencé téléphone
mais ça durait 15 jours avec lui quoi il
a fait son groupe et vous dites une
partie de moi-même si on est allé
on alter ego on disait toujours on est
deux phases de la même pièce on a failli
chanter cette chanson de mecs qui se
regardent dans la même pièce c'était mon
voisin de palier quoi
quand j'étais petit et voilà quoi il m'a
appris beaucoup de choses il m'a emmené
en fait ce que je vous rapporte dans les
chansons je pense que
c'est un peu de sa liberté
en fait on rapporte on rapporte le génie
de ceux qui peuvent qui peuvent pas être
là parce qu'ils sont trop fous
c'est ça un inconnu des mecs trop fous
pour être là et ouais et c'est leur
histoire que je raconte en général dans
mes chansons voilà
vous devez nous éviter Mick Jagger
[Rires]
il faut que personne ne regarde
d'accord personne ne le regarde
non
Estelle Arthur Jean-Louis Aubert je vous
laissez filer vous pouvez revenir pour
le blind test qui va être le grand blind
test de la mort j'espère que vous serez
là
j'accueille Talia Frédéric Beigbeder
Marc Lavoine Florent Pagny Laurent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs ce que vous venez de
voir
si vous venez de voir est-ce qu'il va se
passer à la rentrée
c'est donc Laurent Ruquier qui occupera
la case du samedi soir
non je vais te dire la vérité je suis
ravi que ça soit toi voilà merci
vraiment je vois pas qui m'a été plus
plaisir que toi passons la vérité c'est
qu'il fallait bien qu'ils mettent
quelqu'un à ma place j'avais pas diffusé
l'ami non plus donc autant que ça soit
toi qui est mon ami voilà ça me fait
très plaisir Laurent
ça aurait été je me suis dévoué je me
suis dévoué
merci Laurent voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il y a avec bébé
ils auraient pu te mettre toi ils
auraient pu te mettre toile samedi soir
à ma place quand on te voit chez deniso
on se dit c'est bien talent quel talent
c'est vrai et c'est bizarre ils n'ont
pas pensé alors Frédéric tu connais le
principe de l'émission de ce soir tous
les invités doivent me poser une
question à moi et une question à Laurent
Baffie alors j'espère que tu as
travaillé un peu attention
alors voilà donc c'est une grande
première dans l'histoire de la
télévision ce qui est en train d'arriver
parce que avant on supprimait les
émissions quand elles ne faisait pas
d'audience et donc c'est la première
fois je crois que peut-être que c'est
dans l'histoire de la télévision dans le
monde qu'on arrête une émission qui
marche très très bien c'est là c'est là
ma question à toi Thierry oui
c'est peut-être qu'il y a une raison
autre que celle qui a été invoquée pour
supprimer cette émission peut-être qu'il
y a un secret quelque chose alors je
rappelle qu'il y a une élection
présidentielle en France l'année
prochaine et que c'est là où je vais
faire un petit peu genre bizarre il y a
des coïncidences troublantes je trouve
il y a des coïncidences comme le départ
de Karl Zero de Canal+ au moment où il
fait un film meurtrier sur Jacques
Chirac celui de Serge Julie de
libération donc j'ai apporté ce journal
voilà celui d'Alain Genestar bizarrement
débarqué de par image alors qu'il avait
fait une couverture sur la femme du
ministre de l'Intérieur
le premier en diffamation Denis Robert
qui a révélé l'affaire Clearstream ça
fait cinq avec l'arête tout le monde en
parle ça fait 5 donc c'est des
coïncidence est-ce que tu penses voilà
ma question est-ce que tu penses que il
y a une raison mystère comme il y avait
autrefois des invités mystères je pense
pas je pense pas que mon départ de
France 2 soit dû à des raisons
politiques je pense que c'est un
pataquès qui est pas très intéressant
pour les téléspectateurs mais qui est
vraiment une connerie quoi dans la façon
dont les dans les choses se sont faites
et je pense que si il y avait pas eu ça
serait continué non je rassure tout le
monde je pense pas être évincé pour des
raisons politiques voilà bon c'est
dommage c'est toujours bien je pense que
malheureusement c'est beaucoup plus con
que ça
alors là une question pour moi une
question pour bâti alors écoute est-ce
que tu pourrais me donner trois noms
d'invités qu'une fois absolument pas
inviter le samedi soir Johnny Hallyday
pourquoi parce qu'il est gâté
[Rires]
tu allais voir le spectacle au Palais
des Sports 2h30 sur scène étant non non
non il est juste énorme
à la fin du spectacle j'étais moi plus
fatigué que lui et Laurence est
contraire je vais te demander quels sont
les trois invités qu'il faut absolument
inviter le samedi soir bah Geneviève
Nadine de Rothschild parce qu'on apprend
plein de trucs sur l'étiquette et sur
est-ce que effectivement si c'est trompé
tout ça dans un dîner c'est important de
le savoir et puis en troisième Thierry
parce que si tu irais pas là l'émission
est moins bien
ce sera mon invité c'est une question
pour moi tu t'es fait virer là donc de
la télévision
après
c'est la troisième fois que je me fais
virer de France 2 ce qui veut dire je
suis déjà revenu deux fois donc je suis
assez optimiste
je voudrais savoir à quel moment
tu es passé de
sale con prétentieux avec plutôt sympa
humain super gentil intéressant et il y
a pas deux minutes
[Musique]
et je voudrais savoir comment ça se fait
vers quel âge et tout ça c'est comme
disait Patrick Besson quand tu as réussi
tu peux être altruiste après
j'en ai une mais il va pas aimer merde
parce que ça va être long la réponse ou
très court on sait pas parler pendant
combien de temps 4 5 ans
et je peux savoir alors en vrai ce qu'il
y avait avec cette [__] de marionnette
il avait pas que la marionnette tu
n'étais pas un peu comme Thierry tu t'es
pas très fréquentable à l'époque et je
t'ai retiré mon bonjour comme Pagnol le
faisait voilà maintenant je te redonne
mon bonjour car j'estime que tu es plus
fréquentable
[Musique]
genre une question pour moi alors une
question bah écoute ce soir je vois
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de monde
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui aurait
aimé inviter et qui est pas venu
une question pour ma fille il vient pas
Lennon
je prépare le double des clés je prépare
les clés de bagnole 3 ah merde
qu'on l'a mis à la poubelle
[Musique]
j'ai rangé les cassettes donc cette
semaine pour préparer ces dernières
années j'ai passé la semaine à ranger
les cassettes et j'ai trouvé un truc
avec Marc Lavoine qu'on va regarder 1 2
[Musique]
c'était génial comme le légume
écoute
un peu au départ
tu sais les colibels d'enfants les
manifestations ah bah là
Michou non ta maman
elle en Afrique cette année et j'ai
vraiment passé beaucoup de temps dans
les Massaï le berceau de l'humanité
c'est déjà mis un string
pour le film de Vincent Ravalec pour
titre de la racaille
c'était rigolo il me disait Marc il faut
que tu le fasses sinon je le ferais pas
nu bon alors je te coupe la [__] au
montage il me disait c'est même pas la
peine d'y penser
la dernière question des fans c'est tu
as une grosse [__] c'est con comme
question
non franchement pas je pense pas de ta
vie
mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
ressemble on a tous dit en même temps 1
2 3 magnéto Serge
[Musique]
je vais essayer de trouver ce mot
mon frère
[Musique]
j'espère
en plus j'espère
son caractère
[Musique]
j'espère voilà Marc Lavoine j'espère
extrait de l'heure d'été c'est chez
Mercury mesdames messieurs
toujours des gonzesses d'enfer avec toi
[Applaudissements]
tu fais des chansons
encore
c'est la dernière c'est vrai que Sarah a
bien marché là
et alors tu la verrais ça sera encore
plus ta joueur
bah oui quand même imaginons
par an quand même
bien donc c'est vrai qu'après le succès
vous remet avec baryton parce que vous
êtes baryton Martin en fait je suis
marié
parce que là il y avait une demi-heure
il y a d'autres trucs comme ça non tu
peux pas titulaire de la carte de
l'ancien combattante
du travail
valeur capitaux immobilier
un disque classe avec de bonnes
critiques dans les journaux qui vous
ignoraient jusque là un peu plus dur
dans les supermarchés évidemment parce
que plus on monte mon dessin voilà à la
fin on s'accroche je fais partie de la
famille des mords donc faut dire que
vous avez remplacer
Obispo et Calogero parmi aux secs Manset
c'est gonflé quand même non c'est pas
fait exprès c'est comme ça ça vient avec
l'air du temps vous pouvez vous
permettre ce genre de choses maintenant
un là où je t'emmènerai fini par bien
exister en FM là tu vois par exemple
elle est rentrée quatrième au top ah
ouais alors qu'on s'attendait pas à ce
que cette chanson
non plus
et donc moi c'est toujours le but du jeu
c'est de faire en sorte que si c'est
bien fait ça peut d'un seul beaucoup
être une surprise et puis les fêtes
surprise c'est toujours un peu
sympathique
[Musique]
je savais les gens doux
et bien
[Musique]
essaye de faire tout un peu montre un
peu le disque là
je t'emmènerai
[Musique]
j'ai une question vous partez tous les
deux ils sont séparables
en tout cas moi je remercie Monsieur
Caroline de te laisser partir en tout
cas moi je suis très content pour ça
maintenant tu verras c'est bien ça ouais
c'est sympa
comment ça va ça va bien alors qu'est-ce
que tu as fait depuis qu'on s'est pas vu
j'ai fait la météo sur Canal
ensuite première compagnie
et puis toujours les photos
ambassadrice pour un vin à la rentrée de
septembre Laurent il est d'accord pour
te prendre
on sait pas encore comment
c'est pas trompé
de cette semaine j'ai retrouvé tes
exploits mon cher Frédéric
tu te souviens de la vodka ça fait un
peu genre Les enfants de la télé
voilà 1 2 3
magnétos Serge
j'ai accueille maintenant Frédéric
Beigbeder
il va venir
non Catherine
elle me dit quand on vomit on peut pas
parler
oui alors la semaine dernière qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé je me souviens de rien
c'est de l'eau merci beaucoup merci
incroyable c'est quoi de la vodka c'est
à dire que ici on vous sert énormément
de vodka Tony et une fille très
charmante très jolie
me voir est-ce que vous voulez encore un
verre je disais oui etc tout ça se
passait d'une manière sympathique
jusqu'au moment où je me suis dit que
j'étais trop aimé chez pour parler d'un
livre qui est important pour moi mais
c'est bien dans la rue effectivement là
tous les gens pendant une semaine
demandez comment j'allais si je
connaissais l'aspectgicmail
bah oui non je voudrais dire aux gens
qui nous regardent ne faites pas ça chez
vous
c'est mal il ne faut pas
[Musique]
avec Bruno c'est pas une si mauvaise
chaîne que ça finalement
j'ai trouvé aussi un magnéto avec notre
ami Bruno Gaccio très sympathique c'est
le soir où il y avait Sevran tu te
souviens ah ouais ouais 1 2 3 magnéto
c'est
quel conseil donneriez-vous à Pascal
Sevran jeune je donnerai un conseil à
Pascal Sevran que à cette heure-ci doit
être couché bonsoir et voilà
si vous aviez une baguette magique
Pascal vous retrouveriez immédiatement
quelle période de votre vie
j'ai écrit un livre là-dessus j'aimerais
retrouver cette période d'accord
vous aviez une baguette magique vous ne
referiez pas quelle erreur je ne ferai
pas l'erreur de venir ici non préparé
sans savoir qu'il y a cette table
d'accord vous enlèveriez quelle émission
de la grille des programmes si vous
aviez une baguette magique Pascale
il y en a trop il y en a trop à enlever
mais il ne faut rien enlever la liberté
si on avait enlevé les miennes une
époque où vraiment la France avait
besoin de chansons avait besoin de
Dalida avait besoin de Orlando avait
besoin de deux Aznavour bien sûr de qui
serait face à vous face à vous il vous
regarderait du regard vous n'avez plus
rien à dire
ta gueule
il y a un truc qui est sûr c'est que je
suis correcteur ouais il y a un truc qui
est sûr c'est que il nous avait bien
cassé les couilles parce qu'elle se
brosse là je sais pas ce qu'il a mais
avant il était juste ces trucs de vieux
mais là il a il est devenu méchant et
toi il est vraiment c'est l'art de la
ménopause tu crois que c'est
l'andropause
qui est terrible c'est le petit qui le
suit oui je me souvenais plus de ça
quand il se lève et le petit qui pêche
pas aussi moi monsieur d'accord
[Applaudissements]
Christophe Alévêque André Manoukian
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends attends
c'est énorme c'est énorme
le magnifique bonsoir
alors on a un bonsoir donc
Omar vous êtes dans nos jours heureux de
Nakache et Toledano avec Jean-Paul Rouve
et vous êtes un bon acteur moi j'étais
tout à fait sidéré et vous avez raison
de laisser tomber cette [__] de Fred
[__]
et de faire vous-même des films sans lui
enfin sans elle je dirais vraiment bravo
merci beaucoup
depuis le temps que je peux voir en plus
c'est
Eric c'est le pompier c'est le pompier
tout le monde on peut le dire
quand même il est encore plus beau
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mais on va se retrouver sur Canal
à côté je crois juste à côté on est en
train de superviser tu vas avoir un
super truc Christophe ça va mon chat ça
va super bon le succès de l'année
Christophe
moi je vais te dire le samedi dans
l'émission de Rocky on a tout essayé tu
me fais hurler de rire et j'appelle
Barma tous les samedis soirs à 20h pour
dire à l'évêque il est vraiment énorme
quoi c'est vraiment bien
tu as raison qu'est-ce que tu veux que
je te dise
qu'est-ce que tu as fait depuis qu'on
s'est pas vu chérie alors vas-y
travailler sur MCM pendant un an
après j'ai sorti un disque
et puis après j'ai participé à la ferme
à la ferme effectivement voilà
la rentrée
en même temps c'est un peu mon karma
genre j'étais fan de Tonton je vais
serrer la main il était plus président
j'étais fan de Libé j'y suis allé à deux
jours pour la première fois c'est tombé
sur la G ou Julie il est plus là et en
même temps j'arrive ici et c'est la
dernière
écoute
chaque fois que je reçois Liane Foly je
lui parle de toi j'ai dit tu lui as fait
ses plus belles chansons elle aurait dû
rester avec toi enfin c'est grâce à toi
que elle m'a dit un truc enfin tu sais
dans l'autre émission là où on mange
avec Paris Première
et c'est vrai que la question que tu lui
as posé genre pourquoi vous êtes quitté
et
enfin on s'est dit des trucs devant toi
prends s'était jamais dit tous les deux
quoi donc tu as un [__]
c'est mon côté Bataille et Fontaine et
puis il y a mon pelochon
j'étais très frisé ouais et c'est
Jacques chasse d'eau qui m'a appelé
comme ça peu le son parce que grâce à
Jacques je recevais du courrier monsieur
Paul Auchan monsieur Paulson
Alain Delon qui fait César et Brutus son
fils Benoît Poelvoorde Gérard depard
c'est en 2008 février 2008
et toi qu'est-ce que tu fais tu es parti
à Marseille toi ah oui moi j'ai pris
beaucoup de recul pourquoi
j'ai une prise de conscience dans la vie
et j'ai fait un peu comme Nicolas Hulot
Stéphane perron je me suis retiré
complètement je suis parti dans Larzac
tout seul dans une petite ferme et juste
deux chèvres et trois cochonnes
et j'ai une grande conscience sur le
côté écologique sauver la planète tout
ça il y a eu trop d'abus et je suis
beaucoup plus engagé maintenant par
exemple
c'est vrai qu'il faut diminuer les gaz à
effet de serre bon à la fois il y a tous
les spécialistes ils sont d'accord pour
dire que d'ici 20 30 ans il y aura plus
de pétrole donc il faut vite se dépêcher
acheter un gros 4x4
à la fois Cédric ça pollue les 4x4 mais
à la fin 4 en ville c'est indispensable
imagine il a plus il y a une flaque tu
as pas de 4x4
après
il y en a carrément j'achète des des
humeurs
il y a un mur des 4x4 de l'armée
américaine camion meurent ville c'est
aussi con que d'attaquer l'Irak avec des
smart
ah les questions est-ce que tu es allé
voir mon film les jours heureux ouais
j'ai beaucoup aimé vraiment j'ai reçu
Jean-Paul Rouve et je lui ai dit
d'ailleurs je trouve ça un film très
bien en plus il y a une musique que
j'adore c'est les Doobie Brothers
landten running donc ça déjà un film où
il y a ça déjà c'est bien
pose-moi une question comment ça va
je suis partagé entre le soulagement et
la tristesse ça me va pose-moi une
question
s'il te plaît
est-ce que tu sais Paris Première c'est
tromper France 2 apparemment oui surtout
qu'elle a sorti à force de sucer je me
suis fait [__]
pose-moi une question est-ce que tu es
heureux
je rappelle le concept de l'émission je
suis très heureux ce soir parce que j'ai
tous les gens que j'aime que j'ai invité
qui sont venus ils sont là sur le
plateau c'est un peu comme si j'étais
mort et si je voyais toute ma vie défilé
avec mes amis voilà donc tout va bien je
suis heureux
[Musique]
j'ai rangé les cassettes cette semaine
et j'ai trouvé des images de toi dans
tout le monde en parle 1 2 3 magnétos
est-ce que vous feriez un film porno
avec le comique Titeuf celui qui a 2F
mais c'est une idiot ça par contre je
pense que jamais personne l'a fait mais
c'est vrai que
allier du comique et du cul ça peut être
comment on fait pour bander en rayon
mais tu bandes joyeux
quels conseils donneriez-vous Titeuf a
des jeunes qui veulent faire la même
carrière que vous mais de faire comme
moi de commencer par le cinéma
traditionnel pour en faire arriver au
cinéma porno je pense que c'est pour
commencer petit et bondé après
quels ont été les réactions de vos
parents quand ils ont vu que vous
faisiez des films une grande fierté
je suis très fier je remercie ma famille
c'est le travail de toute une équipe
mais dans le scénar porno le travail de
toute une équipe c'est jamais aussi bien
dit
c'est quoi votre surnom sur les plateaux
semaine j'ai trouvé un magnéto avec toi
non oui
1 2 3 magnéto Serge
la nature m'a bien gâtée au niveau de
au niveau le
niveau de l'ascenseur tu veux dire
si l'alcool me gêne dans le travail ça
laisse la finir cette vanne elle a pas
de
j'arrête immédiatement le travail
parce que tu es impressionnant chez
Steevy c'est sa mère
si sa mère non je le dis sérieusement à
sa mère que j'ai rencontré qui est une
femme adorable
la plus grande erreur de ma vie c'est
peut-être la grand-mère de Sylvie
peut-être tu vas en parler
c'est une bonne réponse
je suis fan de au Aznavour peut-être
ça nous fait encore
et alors j'ai retrouvé aussi évidemment
je suis arrêtez-vous les enfants je
viens de retrouver
Fred 1 2 3 magnéto
les plus belles gonzesses mains ou Fred
c'est Omar parce que il en a deux
magnifiques
c'est les plus belles ça me fait plaisir
elle sent comment elles sont belles
l'avenir de l'homme
qui a le plus d'amis dans le showbize ou
Fred c'est ma gloire
Qui a les plus grosses voitures
maroufred mais j'ai trois enfants
[Musique]
qui reçoit le plus de lettres de femmes
je dois marquer
le champ où est-ce que tu vas amener tes
artistes à la rentrée tu t'es demandé un
peu déjà
je me suis demandé mais j'ai pas encore
trouvé de solution je crois que ce qu'on
nous propose à part notre camarade
Ruquier qui va prendre ta place je crois
qu'il va construire ailleurs c'est quand
même le désert difficile très difficile
mais bon je revienne façon on va se
retrouver sur Canal et puis je pense que
ça à mon avis
[Musique]
on passe au blind test
pour jouer avec nous j'accueille liane
folie Michel Vernier et sa fille
Charlotte à la Chabat
gérant Darmon
n'a rien
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Louis Aubert
Frédéric beigbed
le Jamel Comedy Club et Pascal c'est le
problème
[Musique]
je trouve simplement cette émission un
peu confuse j'espère que la semaine
prochaine on fera une émission
[Musique]
alors ce que je voulais d'abord qu'on
présente Charlotte qui est donc la fille
de Bruno Gaccio et Michel Bernier
Charlotte bienvenue parmi nous
[Applaudissements]
justement bon alors ce soir il n'y aura
pas de Paris ça sera du chacun pour sa
gueule dès le départ
Rebecca doit marquer les gagnants et la
sortie on verra qui est le grand
champion de ces huit années de Blind
Test voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la maison
sur la ligne de départ ouais mais
Thierry l'attend attends quoi
ça c'est très important
j'ai ici la liste de ceux qui m'ont
demandé lâchement
les morceaux du blind test
que je n'ai pas donné puisque en 8 ans
nous on n'a jamais divulgué une seule
réponse c'est vrai sauf non non
non non non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai demandé une ville encore
malade
c'est pas bien
et là la déception va être immense je
sais que devant leur télévision il
pleure ouais Laurent Baffie non
les couilles c'est pas vrai
bon alors attention là c'est chacun pour
sa gueule dès le départ il y a pas
d'équipe il y a pas de potes c'est
l'ultra libéralisme
bien de rien donc attention on est tous
concentré
Cortez moi je suis prêt tu es avec moi
je suis prêt envoie le premier morceau
je veux l'interprète Philippe
OK
[Applaudissements]
s'appelle Patrick de Carolis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention Philippe pour le 3 tu es prêt
je suis prêt on y va
[Musique]
c'est entre Jamel et Aubert moi je veux
un replay monsieur
[Musique]
c'est toi
Jamel Debbouze et Amel bravo Amel voilà
Laurent tu es largué toi la fille tu es
où là
donc attention
numéro 4 Philippe Corti
révélation
[Applaudissements]
attention là ça peut changer de camp
Philippe Corti
de toi
je demande je demande un contrôle
d'urine
tout ça n'est pas très normal ça va
faire mal les gens répondent très vite
ça il gagne le Tour de France derrière
là mais Philippe donc il y a personne
qui a gagné deux fois jusqu'à maintenant
à chaque fois
très régulière
on continue attention attendez
parce qu'on centrer là il faut pas être
dans l'excitation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo bravo bravo encore Thomas le seul
le seul
je vous demande de vous arrêter le seul
qui a gagné deux fois jusqu'à maintenant
c'est Thomas
merci Jamel merci merci Jamel moi je
propose un truc aussi pour la montée que
ça fait longtemps qu'on bosse ensemble
quand tu seras ça je serai de dos et tu
trouveras quand même t'arrêtera bien sûr
c'est énorme
tu imagines quand je fais ça tes dodo et
malgré tout
elle peut le faire
des trucs
tu y es là tu es concentré je suis sur
le coup c'est très je suis sur zone je
suis extrêmement content
attention on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention
Philippe Corti
[Musique]
il était dans Rabbi Jacob
et j'en suis fier voilà
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter
deux fois Thomas
pour le moment contrôler c'est ça la
France aujourd'hui bravo
absolument chapeau monsieur
on continue
[Musique]
centre Lavoine et Aubert gâteau
[Applaudissements]
donc pour le moment j'ai d'armement deux
fois Thomas de fois
et la voile une fois ouais
on se concentre tu veux qu'on peut
remettre le morceau d'avant pour qu'il
trouve un truc non
[Musique]
les flammes toujours Michel
ta mère ta mère c'est pas une conne
de France Thierry oui quoi la droite la
gauche devrait se méfier la droite
revienne dangereusement
1 à 250 attention
Annie
c'est tout pardon pardon qui pardon chef
bien
sûr
on passe au micro banco attention on
passe au micro banco ah c'est très drôle
dans la série des banco attention
le micro banco le 13 le 13 j'entends je
viens
ici attention
monsieur
je suis à la gicle
le trio
tu es l'incarnation du service public
pour moi pour moi attention on passe au
mini banco le 14 et vas-y joue-le là
au début les autres disaient ouais il
est vieux il va moins vite c'est le
Zidane du blender
énorme là tu sais que ton disque est un
tuilerie là
donc
c'est Darmon pour le moment qui est en
tête de tout le monde
c'est comme ça
la chanson quand on est heureux
moi je voulais en profiter pour pour
demander à l'équipe adverse de nous
excuser
sincèrement le désolé tout le monde
groupe se joue à l'eau on est d'accord
on se dit
le grand vainqueur est quand même là
[Applaudissements]
on passe maintenant au super banco
le super banco
[Musique]
ins
donc c'est un point pour qui c'est à mes
enfants on la prend
tout refaire du début les gens ne
comprennent pas dernière il faut tout
réorganiser je vais vous demander de
sortir
et c'est France et on va rappeler
Jean-Marie Bigard calmez-vous il y en a
pour 8 heures
moi-même je voulais pas le mettre dans
le blind test Béatrice a insisté je
voulais pas je voulais pas parce que
c'est trop dur voilà j'écoute ma femme
et je pense que j'ai eu le temps parce
que je pense que vous avez pas trouvé
moi je connais mon patron
ou pas elle est bien
est arrivé le super méga bocaux de la
mort
et après c'est fini fini
[Applaudissements]
super méga banco de la mort
concentration
bon alors maintenant
on est on est quatre pour Darmand 4 pour
Thomas s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
on passe
est-ce que Thomas et Darman pourrait se
mettre à côté s'il vous plaît
c'est prêt attention 1 2 3
est-ce que tu peux souffler plus discret
attention attention
[Rires]
il faut qu'on trouve un vainqueur merde
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
va nous faire un cadeau formidable parce
que chaque fois que j'arrête une
émission je mets voilà c'est fini
pour la première fois Jean-Louis va me
la chanter en vrai et je te remercie
j'ai une petite
[Applaudissements]
très beau cadeau
voilà
c'est fini on attend ressassé les mêmes
théories on a tellement tiré chacun de
notre côté
que voilà
c'est fini trouve un autre rocher petite
huître perlée ne laisse pas trop couler
de temps sous ton petit nez
et Thierry car c'est fini
c'est fini
[Musique]
voilà
c'est fini on va pas GIR au revoir comme
sur le quai d'une gare je dis seulement
bonjour et fais gaffe à l'amour
voilà
c'est fini aujourd'hui ou demain c'est
le moment où t'aimais peut-être après
demain tu nous retrouvons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car c'est fini
c'est fini
ta fille par te dire qu'on éviterait le
pire
qu'il fallait mieux couper plutôt que
déchirer
tu as fini par te dire que peut-être on
va grandir
[Musique]
que même si c'est non et que même si
c'est con
tous les deux nous savons
que de toute façon
voilà
c'est fini le sois jamais amer reste
toujours sincère tu as eu ce que tu as
voulu même si t'as pas voulu ce que tu
as eu
voilà
c'est fini le demain se desserre de
s'être trop serré la foule nous emporte
chacun de notre côté
car c'est fini
c'est fini
allez à l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
professionnelle jusqu'au bout c'était
tout le monde en parle avec Laurent
bassin
il y a un petit problème c'est qu'il y a
des gens qui voudraient pas que ça se
finisse trop tôt donc on va organiser
une mutinerie donc on va vous allez
m'aider à virer on va prendre le pouvoir
et l'émission va pas se terminer parce
qu'on va la perdre jusqu'à plus soif
allez encore
bonsoir
alors parlez-nous un peu de ton acte de
l'été
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'amis comme toi
Jean-Marie Bigard mon petit va mieux du
15 septembre au 28 octobre au théâtre
comédien à Paris Charlotte Gainsbourg
Alain Chabat la science des rêves de
Michel Gondry avec Gaëlle Garcia Bernard
Miou-Miou et madele sorti le 16 août et
prête-moi ta main derrière l'artigo il
est voilà sortie le 1er novembre Jamel
Debbouze Jamel Comedy Club tous les
samedis à 20h sur Canal+ à partir du 15
juillet madame messieurs Michel Bernier
de le reste
à partir du 22 septembre Jean-Louis
Aubert l'album s'appelle Idéal Standard
il est en tournée Élie Semoun Elie
Semoun se prend pour qui en tournée et
du 22 septembre 10 septembre à la voile
l'album s'appelle l'heure d'été en
tournée et le 6 juillet au Zénith de
Paris s'est passé
Titeuf à partir du 10 octobre au Théâtre
du Gymnase Florent Pagny l'album
s'appelle abracadabra Arthur Arthur en
vrai entouré dans toute la France et à
partir du 18 janvier au Théâtre du
Gymnase Estelle Lefébure frontière de
Xavier Jans avec Aurélien Vic
Ivan Attal Frédéric Beigbeder Gérard
Darmon liane folie une étoile d'or et en
tournée et le 18 novembre au Grand Rex
de Paris Laurent Ruquier Dany Boon
Geneviève de Fontenay Bruno Gaccio
Omar et Fred Christophe à Dominique
Segal quand il Thalia Laetitia voilà
une amie
[Applaudissements]
au revoir merci et à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]
je suis trop belle
merci à tous
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu